Russia's defense Ministry says it's shot
down four and intercepted a fifth
Ukrainian drone in and around Moscow on
Tuesday morning it accuses Ukraine of
carrying out what it calls a terrorist
attack operations and a Moscow airport
were temporarily affected for more on
this story let's bring in Julian
shapovalova in Moscow hello there Yulia
what more have you learned about these
attacks and the impact on that airport
well indeed we've heard from the
ministry of Defense as well as Moscow
mayor serbiani and he confirmed that
areas in new Moscow in the southwest as
well as the southwestern part of the
Moscow region were attacked by at least
five drones one of them as you said was
jammed with electronic warfare system
near cubinka Military Air Base where
worlds renowned aerobatic steam are
based and they train there as well Cuban
case located in close proximity to a
number of military infrastructure
facilities including a labino range the
Patriot Park Etc so these are the places
where the annual Army Forum takes place
as well as the renowned Tang biathlon
competition and so on so the Drone no
doubt posed some serious threat to all
those objects luckily no casualties or
damage were reported that agencies also
report about four more unmanned aerial
Vehicles shut down in new Moscow in
total air defense and electronic welfare
forces repelled attacks by five as you
mentioned uavs and as we understand
according to emergency service Services
probably some minor damage allegedly was
reported uh due to the debris falling
debris over those uh objects uavs also
according to them the drones or
Ukrainian they were shot down by Air
Defense Forces and for safety reasons
about 14 flights were redirected from
nukaba International Airport to other
airports in Moscow but from eight
o'clock Moscow time that's five o'clock
GMT the restrictions on the flights in
the airport area have been canceled and
now we have information that airport has
resumed its work also according to the
ministry of Defense they commented on
the morning drone attack in new Moscow
and the Moscow region and basically they
said that it was an attempt by the key
of regime to carry out a terrorist
attack with five drones so according to
them there were no casualties and no
damage and Ministry also has said that
in their statements that
basically all the attacks have been
repelled so we're following the
developments here and what we can say
now is that the Russian Ukrainian
conflict is unfolding on Russian soil at
the moment all right thanks so much for
the update Julio shapovalova in Moscow